SPEAKER: Our program helps
students learn, build,
and get certified on
Google Cloud Platform.
The Associate Cloud
engineer track
consists of the
following benefits.
First, students and faculty
receive a 100% discount
to pursue the architecting
with Google Cloud Platform
specialization on Coursera.
In addition, we are also
making hands-on training
available in the form of
self-based labs on Qwiklabs.
Here, again, there's
a 100% discount
to access the Cloud Architecture
Quest and other labs.
Finally, we want both
students and faculty
to prepare for certification.
To prepare for and earn the
Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification, faculty who have
completed the specialization
receive a 100% discount
on the certification exam.
A student discount
is also available.
Students who are familiar
with basic concepts related
to operating systems,
networking, databases,
and programming are good
candidates for this program.
What do you and your students
learn in the Associate Cloud
Engineer Track?
The Architecting with Google
Cloud Platform Specialization
on Coursera comprises
six courses.
The specialization
introduces learners
to the comprehensive and
flexible infrastructure
and platform services provided
by Google Cloud Platform.
Through a combination
of presentations,
demos, and hands on labs,
learners explore and deploy
solution elements, including
infrastructure components
such as networks, systems,
and application services.
This course also covers
deploying practical solutions,
including securely
interconnecting networks,
customer supplied encryption
keys, security and access
management, coders and billing,
and resource monitoring.
In the cloud architecture
quests spanning 11 hours
the labs have been
curated to give learners
hands on practice with
topics and services
that appear in the Associate
Cloud Engineer Certification
exam.
From IAM, to networking, to
Kubernetes engine deployment,
this quest is composed of
specific labs that will put
your GCP knowledge to the test.
In addition to this
quest, learners also
have access to other labs.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer track
must be completed in 16 weeks.
This slide shows a
suggested timeline.
Complete the Architecting
with Google Cloud Platform
Specialization within
the first nine weeks.
Complete the Cloud
Architecture Quest
and additional hands-on
labs by week 16.
Complete the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification exam
before the voucher
expiration date.
Students can definitely
race ahead of the timeline.
Learners completing
the Architecting
with Google Cloud
Platform Specialization
will earn a Coursera
completion certificate,
which can be shared with
prospective employers
and a professional network.
The Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification exam objectively
measures an individual's ability
to demonstrate the critical job
skills required for the role.
The exam duration is two hours.
The format is multiple
choice and multiple select.
This exam must be
taken in person
at one of our testing
center locations.
For more details, visit the
Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification web page.
Some of the faculty
responsibilities
are registering for and
attending online onboarding
sessions, enrolling
and managing students
on your Coursera program--
ideally your cohort has 60
to 200 students per faculty,
monitoring student's learning
progress and nudging students
who may be falling behind.
conducting study jams to support
student's learning progress--
study jams are essentially
workshops that you conduct
with your students, earning
your Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification, and
encouraging students
to become certified to
validate technical expertise.
For more information,
refer to the faculty FAQs.
Google Cloud has ensured
that you, as faculty,
are enabled to run this
program successfully
in your college or institution.
You get administrative
access on Coursera
to monitor students learning
progress in real time.
The Faculty Resource Center
provides enhanced support
to faculty with program
related materials,
including student FAQs and a
guide on conducting study jams.
Your students will
also get access
to a student Resource Center.
Faculty and students can contact
the Coursera and Qwiklabs
support teams for any
platform related issues.